national master james canty iii here
with chess.com
and today we have game of the day with
the white pieces we have
stock fish and with the black pieces we
have leela chess
zero let's get right into it guys so
first move what do you think an e4
d4 knight f3 c4 b3 larson system maybe
g3 or h3 move
one from stock fish wow don't try this
at home
or maybe try it because stockfist is
doing it now h3 move one
wow well e5 is next here now a little
bit about this h3 move of course what it
is
is it's gonna transpose into many
different openings now h3 move one is
definitely strange
but it can have some merit to it as it
does transpose into different openings
that you may see every day
with just the early inclusion of h3 move
one
now e5 and then e4 so of course after h3
once again
when h3 happens and you see this in your
own games you just want to control the
center
so e5 from lila chess e4 and then knight
f6
and knight f3 we have a petrov in a way
but h3
early h3 kind of strange here and after
knight f3 here
of course we have d5 from leela chest
zero so strike in the center immediately
which is something you should always do
in every game strike the center
immediately after d5 there's e takes d5
and a temporary pawn sacrifice
with the move e4 attacking the knight on
f3 so we need to move it it could be
dangerous and he says hey
you know what i'm going right into this
95 let's see what you do
queen takes d5 from lula just zero and
then we have d4 here so now it's
defending the knight and defending the
knight here
and also stopping the queen of course
from capturing but uh striking
the center once again getting the bishop
out as well and it's defending my knight
great move here we do have al pasant
which could happen and a deadly threat
on the board
of bishops c4 attacking the f7 pawn um
and also hitting the queen as well so
after d4 there's e takes d3
on facade and then after e takes d3 you
have to take with the knight if you
don't want to lose material
so knight takes d3 strange knight on d3
pawn on h3
strange game here after knight c6 and
knight c3 what does this look like
for all you scandinavian players out
there or the center counter players
this is exactly what it looks like some
type of scandinavian with a early h3
on the board as it did transpose just
like we said
it will transpose into a lot of
different openings queen to a5 is on the
board scandinavian fashion
you can't play bishop d2 stockfist
chooses bishop to e2
and then bishop to d7 maybe we're
looking at a castle queen side
so castle kingside and the castle queen
side from leela chest zero now
this is one of those positions that if
you get this of course opposite side
capsules one capsules kingside
one castle's queenside the plans are
very simple whoever gets to the king
first
in these type of positions is going to
win immediately
so it's all a race let's see who gets to
the king first bishop e3 of course
developing our pieces this is still the
development phase
get the pieces out formulate your plans
bishop e3 and then queen to f5 uh
transferring the queen to the king side
of the board things like bishop d6 can
happen and if you see sometimes in the
aggressive
opposite side castle scandinavians
you'll see g5 and g4
moving the rook to g8 and trying to
develop mate as quickly as possible
queen five and then a4 from stockfish
saying hey
i am going to get to your king first or
at least try to
a4 and a6 so this move right here is
actually what you call a hook
pawn where a lot of times you can
actually either sacrifice or play b4 and
b5
and you have a target already so after
a6 well bishop f3
says i'm going to get both of my bishops
on this side of the board
where the action is and where i should
be attacking and black does the same
my bishops and my pieces are pointing to
this side of the board again guys
it's a race and we don't know who's
going to win that race yet
bishop d6 now take a look at this
position it is white to move
what would you do in this position to
continue your attack
well here it is guys maybe you can play
something like rig b1 b3
g3 g4 rookie one knight d5 maybe 95 is
no good it hangs a piece but
here's what stockfish says stockfish
says uh very simple
we're just going to play knight b5 not
that simple at all
tricks you there knight b5 when we lie
that's a big boy move
wow now after knight b5 of course uh
leela chess stops and thinks and says
you know what
you're gonna have to show me a takes b5
i'm going for it
because i am leela zero after a takes b5
there's a takes b5 and now the rook file
is open
rook a8 is definitely going to be made
if this knight moves so something like
so queen takes b5 allowing us to defend
the check with knight to b8
rook a8 and knight b8 does happen and
then we have to keep the attack going
once you sacrifice material it is
suicide it is not good
you should not be able to play slow
chess
after you sacrifice a piece there are
rare occasions in rare cases but you
need to keep the attack going so
bishop a7 attacks tonight rook takes b8
is mate
so c6 here defends the knight on b8
very simple but this bishop is now what
we call loose loose pieces are
undefended
so we have something we can do with it
after c6 there's knight to c5 very
strong move attacking the bishop
on d6 trying to remove the defender and
if bishop takes c5 well then we have
moves like rook takes b8 or even bishop
takes ba could be very very devastating
getting out of there and checkmating
very soon knight c5 and king c7
defending the bishop and also defending
the knight with both of the rooks here
and the rooks are connected
and then bishop e2 from stockfish again
guys once you sacrifice a piece
you got to keep going you have to keep
attacking you have to keep the
initiative up initiative is
time and activity and you got to keep
going you got to keep threatening things
so bishop e2 attacking the queen
queen to b4 attack it again queen f4
you're threading mate whoa
attack it again back up and then queen
to f5 or queen to e5 here
after cleaning five guys you got a lot
of moves you can make here maybe f4
maybe knight d3 maybe b4 queen b3 right
now take a second here and look at this
position and what would you play as
white
well here's what stockfish says
stockfish says you know what this is
what i'm going to play right here
real close come in real close lean in
here it is you ready
knight takes b7 is on the board oh my
goodness
yes it's one of those type of games guys
knight takes b7 is on the board that's
very very strong
well let's see what happens if we
actually take the knight which didn't
happen but if king takes b7
you have this cool line of queen b3
check king takes a8 and then brook to a1
and you're done that's a wrap there guys
queen b5 is the best move sacrificing
the queen because there's made threats
literally
everywhere so after queen b5 instead of
taking the queen when you find a good
move you look for a better one
so bishop c5 check um discovery king
ghost to b7
rook a7 check king to c8 and a beautiful
move here you don't even have to take
the queen
you don't have to i mean you probably
can but bishop takes d6 threatening rook
c7
mate now my queen's hanging you can take
it if you like rook c7 is made and we
great
wow beautiful type of game there knight
takes b7 on the board so leela chess
says okay you know what you know hey
i know you're kind of serious we're just
gonna do this bishop takes h3 so we're
gonna
open the file here maybe have something
to deal with later
let's see what happens bishop takes h3
we take the rook on d8
it just says oh we got bishop takes b8
coming a lot of a lot of decisiveness
working on here
a lot of tactics in this game rook takes
d8 and then bishop to b6
check very strong check here if king
takes you have moves like queen check
and of course rook to a6 and the right
right situation the knights on here
right now
but usually you would see something like
queen of b3 check in this next uh series
and after king back to c7 rook to a7
king ca queen b7
mate and we great so now bishop b6
there's pieces hanging everywhere
king b7 this is hanging this is hanging
everything's hanging right and here's
another cool move rook a7 check
threatening if king takes b6 queen b5
once again and rook to a1
and you're done this is awesome rick a7
check king c8
he goes back and then we go rookie one
getting a rook off the file with a smile
bishop a6 with the discovery attacking
the queen wow
stockfish came to play today this is
nasty rookie one rook d7 i gotta get rid
of some of these pieces
we gotta start trading after rook to d7
there's queen to a1 which is a very cool
move here
getting an activating queen on this side
of the board now you could have played
bishop check anyway
but again when you find a good move you
look for a better one
queen a1 is actually better due to
calculation being stockfish calculating
very good stuff queen a1 there's a lot
of chests left so let's fly through a
few moves
rook takes and queen takes a7 and then
knight to e4 here
so of course now my pieces are starting
to advance i do have things like knight
takes g3 in the air here
so when you have these kind of
situations your opponent has counter
play you got to keep the initiative or
keep whatever you have going as fast as
humanly possible
94 bishop a6 check let's go says
stockfish knight takes queen takes and
then we have king to d7
best move only move in a way and then
after king d7 there's queen b7 check
running the king somewhere king goes
over to e6
now we keep the attack going keep the
threats up if you notice how many times
stockfish made threats
it makes the position much better for
stockfish even being down a piece here
but only temporarily after king e6
there's bishop d4 attack the queen
and rook takes e4 is going to be very
strong so queen to d5
and you know starfish says you know what
it's time to get my piece back you know
your king's in the center of the board
in the
middle of the street looking crazy here
and queen c8 check king e7 and takes
this position is already winning this
game is basically over
now we still have chess left let's see
what happens but beautiful sacrifice on
that side of the board whoever gets to
the king first right is going to win and
if you look at the king structure here
this king was castled this king still
is castle so it's all about who gets to
the king first king to d8
bishop b6 check we're keeping the
threats alive bishop to c7 and we trade
or actually we take on h7 first because
this is a better way of doing it
as you can take tonight but it is going
to be a trade queen takes h7 bishop
takes and queen takes
now the rest of this game is going to be
technique pretty simple but
this game is over we're up in exchange
we're doing better we're up upon here
king safety is
disgusting for black here white's going
to win this game let's see how
queen takes e4 rook takes in king d7
this is
a theoretically winning endgame you
should be able to win this end game
as a human here let's see some technique
rook g4 attacked the g7 pawn
g6 defending the pawn king f1 stepping
out of the pin for the win
and also you have to make sure that you
get your king to the center of the board
to help you
in whatever you're trying to do king to
e6 here and then we have a rook to a4
sliding to the other side of the board
we have past pawns
now you have to think about our path a
pass pawn you have to think about this
in an in game when you're in an in game
the most important thing you should be
worrying about
even in the middle game in the beginning
of course is the pawn structure
what are the pawns look like the
skeleton of the pawns so that means if
we remove the rook and the bishop
in the situation it's already a winning
endgame actually and how you would do
that is we have the two pass pawns here
or the one actually we're going to
create one pass pawn on this side of the
board
and then we're going to use our king is
what we call a fox in the chicken coop
from jeremy showman's in-game course is
what you'll be doing is actually using
the king to gobble up these pawns while
this king is actually trying to stop the
pass pawn on this side of the board
now this is only looking at the pawns
but that's enough to help you find an
idea
a strategy a plan to end up winning this
end game king to d6
king e2 king d7 and rook before
attacking the bishop
bishop c7 rook b7 then we have king c8
and
you would think you would just move your
rook right rook before maybe keep the
rook on the board but
this is why we explained the pawn
structure first about a winning end game
and what you should do
because look at this damn rotate c7 who
would do that
how many of you would have done rook
takes c7 in this position
wow it's almost a baffling move but in
fact it's actually winning because of
the skeleton pawn structure here
when we get to the end game these pawns
are easy to clean or
we're going to use it to to make a pass
pawn this king's gonna come over here
and snatch these
while we go up in queen let's see king
of three king d6 king e4
king c5 king e5 we now have an
opposition here
king f6 is going to be a thing as well
he plays king c4 and he says oh okay
you're going for this pawn
cool past pawns must be pushed so f4
happens king b3 king f6
and c5 he's trying to get there as
quickly as possible but unfortunately
he's going to be too late we're going to
gobble these queen this one
sack on this one queen this one in the
game's over c5 and then
king takes f7 c4 king takes g2 and king
a2
engine move that's definitely an engine
move you should just take the pawn right
might as well try
but you know this game's losing king a2
f5 king b3
f6 king c2 doesn't even take the pawn
that's how you know it's bad the engine
does not take the pawn but the humans we
would probably just snatch these pawns
up
because this one is just hopelessly over
now after f7 king to b3 king f5
king c2 we're gonna fast forward here
pretty simple stuff queen the pawn
queen f2 threatening made in many
different ways king c1
king to d4 and the reason sometimes that
you keep these pawns especially maybe if
you're playing bullet chest
or low on time is because your opponent
may be able to stalemate you
um in these type of situations king to
b1 king takes c4
king b3 king b1 no matter where you move
there's going to be checkmate
king b1 is the only move actually and
queen to anywhere on the back rank
will be made queen f1 is was chosen by
stockfish here
and checkmate is on the board that was
awesome that sack right there was
amazing especially with the knight to b5
uh capturing back on b5 putting the rook
on a8
and just always pushing initiative
activity
how do my pieces look who's counsel to
what side of the board who's getting to
the king first
these things were very very important in
this game and i hope you learned
something and can apply them
to your own games i'm national master
james canton iii here with chess.com
and i'll see you guys on the next video